[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat vous le savez
la promesse et dans le titre donné du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
et voici le sommaire de ce 21 mars
Emmanuel Macron a donc choisi l'égalité
de TF1 et France 2 ce mercredi à 13h
pour défendre sa réforme des retraites
et tirer les leçons d'une crise
politique qui a failli emporter sa
première ministre hier avec une motion
de censure rejetée à 9 voix près à
l'assemblée que peut faire le président
va-t-il céder à la violence grandissante
comment redonner du sens à son second
quinquennat réponse dans une minute et
puis pour notre second débat
volontairement décalé vous le savez de
l'actu du jour c'est un zoom sur le
service national universel que je vous
propose le ministre de l'éducation
nationale voudrait progressivement le
rendre obligatoire est-ce réaliste le
général Philippe de Villiers a des
doutes
15 jours ça sert à rien vous le savez
c'est pendant des mois qu'il faut vivre
ensemble voir cette difficulté ça
apprendre à se connaître les points
forts les points faibles les qualités
les défauts etc
nostalgie du service militaire ou levier
indispensable de promotion des valeurs
républicaines on en débat tout à l'heure
du service national universel ce sera
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
le jour d'après la motion de censure
gouvernement dans la majorité
présidentielle chez les LR les fractures
les blessures mettront du temps à
cicatriser Jérôme Rabier au lendemain
d'une censure éviter à neuf ou après on
serre les rendus côté de l'exécutif ce
matin Emmanuel Macron a réuni les ténors
de la majorité à l'Élysée avec un
message pas de dissolution pas de
remaniement pas de référendum le chef de
l'État a tout de même demandé à ses
troupes de réfléchir à une nouvelle
façon de gouverner dans les prochains
mois la première ministre a enchaîné
avec une tournée des groupes de la
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
Renaissance modem et horizon pour faire
le point après le texte retraite adopté
Elisabeth borne a tenu à Matignon une
réunion en présence de tout le
gouvernement
au lendemain
[Musique]
s
je voulais tout d'abord vous remercier
chacun pour votre engagement pas
question pour elle de démissionner et
après avoir fait la tournée de ses
soutiens la première ministre a dû se
confronter aux oppositions à l'Assemblée
où elle a été assaillie de questions la
pressant de retirer son texte ou de
démissionner mes droites dans ses bottes
la première ministre a défendu un texte
fruit du débat parlementaire le texte
sur lequel j'ai engagé ma responsabilité
et celui d'un compromis parlementaire
et nécessaire pour assurer l'avenir de
notre système de retraite par
répartition et nous avons travaillé avec
des parlementaires sur tous les bancs à
la rendre plus juste si Elisabeth borne
est en première ligne nombre de députés
ont ciblé Emmanuel Macron face à une
situation politique sans majorité et des
manifestations qui se poursuivent dans
tout le pays le président de la
République va rompre le silence et
s'exprimer deux mains à 13h devant les
Français dans l'espoir d'apaiser une
situation politique et sociale pour le
moins agité
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Sophie Coignard bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste au Point
hauteur de la tyrannie de la médiocrité
qui est publiée aux éditions de
l'Observatoire Jean-Daniel Lévy bonsoir
bonsoir
Harry s'interactif Amiens bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue auteur de une
république à bout de souffle qui vient
de paraître c'est aux éditions du Seuil
vous êtes journaliste à Mediapart et
docteur en sciences politiques et mise à
palski bonsoir ça existe en
communication politique et éditorialiste
pour sens publique bienvenue à vous
aussi on va évidemment parler longuement
de ce qu'on peut attendre de la prise de
parole de du prénom République demain à
13h mais d'abord je voudrais quand même
revenir sur les leçons de cette motion
de censure votée par
278 députés Sophie Coignières
l'expression que j'ai le plus entendu
depuis hier c'est le vent du boulet je
pense que on l'a tous employé au moins
une fois nos discussions et Isabelle
borne forcément elle est quoi encore
plus fragilisée on ne peut dire que ça
ce soir alors oui c'est à dire que je
trouve que il faut distinguer
l'institutionnel du politique parce que
institutionnellement elle est renforcée
enfin c'est juste une question j'allais
dire elle est encore là elle est encore
là elle est encore là et bon c'est neuf
petites voix comme ça a été beaucoup dit
aussi mais voilà elle est confortée elle
n'a pas été renversée donc
institutionnellement
elle est droit dans ses bottes si j'ose
dire maintenant évidemment politiquement
c'est une autre histoire c'est à dire
que
c'est quand même c'est pour employer une
autre image que le vent du boulet c'est
la double lame de rasoir c'est à dire
que vous avez quand même le jeudi le
49-3 qui déclenche tout ce qu'on sait et
tout ce qu'on a vu et puis le lundi
c'est énorme surprise c'est-à-dire
encore une fois à neuf fois prêt
personne ne s'y attendait ni
au sein de l'exécutif
ni au sein de la majorité relative et
j'allais ajouter
de la bouche on va forcément consacrer
un chapitre de ce premier débat haut où
elle est j'en ai une vie justement 19
députés d'ailleurs qui qui votent
l'ascenseur si on inverse c'est la
preuve que la loi n'aurait pas y a un
orage n'aurait jamais eu la majorité on
comprend un posteriori pourquoi il y a
eu l'usage du 49-3 parce que vous dites
ça en tout cas c'est pas si on regarde
en fait les comptes qui étaient faits de
la part de l'Élysée de la part de
Matignon jeudi dernier en fait c'est à
dire juste avant le fait de décider de
procéder au 49-3 ils estimaient qu'entre
deux et cinq voix ça ne passait pas
voilà alors après on sera jamais
exactement parce que on aura jamais les
résultats réels du vote quoi qu'il en
soit c'est effectivement l'enseignement
principal vous avez quasiment un tiers
des députés LR qui ne sont pas abstenus
mais qui ont voté la motion de censure
donc c'est un signe politique
extrêmement fort et c'est un signe
politique d'autant plus fort que
l'objectif stratégique de la part du
gouvernement on le voyait depuis
quelques semaines c'était quand même de
s'adresser à ces 61 députés républicain
à travers les messages à travers les
orientations et à travers la CMP dont
maintenant tout le monde connaît
parfaitement l'existence
absolument qui vise à faire en sorte de
faire entre guillemets la synthèse entre
ce qui est rétabli au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale que les
différentes qui ont pu être procédés
étaient clairement des messages non
seulement à les garder LR mais à l'égard
DLR récalcitrant et que pour autant ça
n'a pas suffi et donc on a non seulement
aujourd'hui en fait une situation qui
est inconfortable pour le gouvernement
mais surtout lorsqu'il se projette vers
demain ouvert après-demain une
difficulté à pouvoir saisir qu'ils vont
réussir à élargir leur majorité à gauche
ça c'est quasiment évident mais
également à droite même pour des textes
ou des textes assez emblématiques et
peut-être que le prochain qui arrive qui
est un texte immigration qu'il a aussi
entre guillemets et fléchés pour
s'adresser à l'électorat LR et également
au député LR à une potentialité ne
serait-ce que même que de présentation
devant le Parlement qui aujourd'hui
apparaît comme étant limité alors
effectivement si on s'en tient aux
institutions bon bah le la loi elle peut
déjà désormais entrer en vigueur famille
escalonna pousse et fait dans leur
respect de la constitution même si on
peut critiquer l'usage de différents
articles pour reprendre l'expression un
passage en force
et pourtant finalement dans cette
séquence est-ce que vous y voyez un un
nouveau symptôme de ce que vous décrivez
dans dans votre livre c'est à dire
qu'une finalement d'une cinquième
république qui aboutsou oui j'y vois un
nouveau symptôme alors moi c'est ce
cette crise d'origine j'ai hésité
employé le terme je parle pas de je dis
pas que la survie du régime est en jeu
mais je parle d'une crise rampante de
légitimation moi j'ai écrit le bouquin à
l'automne en vacances de la Toussaint je
pouvais pas anticiper tout ce qui s'est
produit ici et je crois que ça ça
illustre complètement
cette difficulté en fait à légitimer
légitimer une décision et ça nous a
rappelé d'ailleurs je je réagis aussi
aux propos précédents que ce
gouvernement est on parle souvent de
majorité relative mais dans toutes les
démocraties parlementaires on parle de
gouvernement minoritaire quant à
gouvernement gouverne de cette façon et
cette notion de censure les résultats on
nous ont rappelé que c'était un
gouvernement minoritaire et donc il
était vulnérable alors après on dira oui
mais regarde enfin on a pas la culture
des coalition surtout
alors après on pourrait ma chronique des
fois en disant mais vous aurez regardez
son pas fiables on peut retourner
l'accusation disons que la macronie n'a
pas su non plus construire ses compromis
mais je pense que si le boulet est passé
si près c'est aussi parce que les
députés votent en fonction d'un contexte
on a eu d'autres des d'émotions de
censure qui ont été qui ont été rejetées
bien plus largement et donc l'enjeu là
c'est qu'on a cette réforme avec ce
mouvement social massif et inédit
quasiment historiquement il faut
remonter très loin pour trouver des
précédents aussi impressionnants et donc
ça montre là une forme de d'impasse
institutionnel et ce sentiment de gâchis
de désillusion je crois qu'il que voilà
que non non je tourne autour dans le
bouquin et qui trouve là une sorte de
d'apothéose presque est-ce que pour
autant vous parler les uns les autres de
crise de régime je commence avec vous
une crise politique on n'est pas encore
dans une crise d'origine une crise de
régime ça voudrait dire en fait
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement est en
incapacité complète de pouvoir agir on
aurait eu mais vous venez de me dire que
le texte sur l'immigration sera très
compliqué
trésorerie ça aurait été une crise de
régime si hier il y avait eu plus de 287
députés qui a évoqué la motion de
censure là pour le coup ça aurait été
clairement une crise de régime et quand
on regarde par le passé il y a eu des
émotions de censure qui ont obtenu
encore plus de voix que c'est le compte
obtenu hier et si je me trompe pas au
moment du gouvernement Bérégovoy donc ça
date un petit peu il y avait eu trois
voix
près ça n'était pas passé à l'époque les
communistes c'était allié à la droite ce
qui là pour le coup apparaissait comme
étant une forme de une forme de surprise
ce que nous on trouve très intéressant
et c'est qu'on a en une semaine de temps
changer complètement de nature de débat
il y a une semaine on parlait que de la
retraite à 64 ans et que c'était
vraiment l'enjeu central et que là la
question de fond elle est remise en
deuxième ou en troisième position et on
est beaucoup plus sur la question de
forme sur la méthode de gouvernement la
méthode politique parce qu'on l'appelle
parfois oui c'est ça la méthode
politique la gouvernance et la capacité
va pouvoir nouer des alliances et même
quand vous regardez les mobilisations
sociales qui s'opèrent depuis jeudi soir
qui sont des mobilisations sporadiques
qui sont des mobilisations d'une partie
de la jeunesse qui sont des mobilisation
pour partie très peu encadrées par les
organisations syndicales on parle de
quoi on parle de 49-3 on parle en fait
d'une d'une critique à l'égard de la
démocratie ou du fonctionnement
démocratie et on a complètement remisé
les interrogations et le fond qui avait
amené aujourd'hui cette contestation je
reviens vers vous dans un instant
familiation mais est-ce que ça veut dire
que il y a eu une sous-estimation
peut-être qu'il y avait pas le choix on
a bien compris que a pris d'après les
décompte elle passait pas là mais
essayez une sous-estimation Sophie
Cognard de l'effet de ce 49-3 sur
l'opinion sur une partie des Français
c'est compliqué à dire parce que il y a
de toute façon il y avait pas d'issue ce
que je veux dire c'est que pas de bonne
solution vous êtes face à des solutions
qui sont toutes qui vous sont toutes
défavorables vous essayez de choisir la
moins mauvaise autrement dit le retrait
je ne sais pas la peine que que je vous
fasse de longs discours après vous voyez
bien que Emmanuel Macron c'est tellement
accroché à l'idée que cette réforme
était la pierre angulaire de son second
quinquennat que bon c'est une enfin
c'est un lieu comme un de le dire mais
effectivement si il retire ce s'il le
retire bah c'est la fin de son
quinquennat c'est un peu beaucoup dit
mais ça va être très compliqué par la
suite qu'est-ce qu'il y avait comme
autre hypothèse aller au vote ou
utiliser le 49-3 donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle c'est ce que les pilotes de
langue anglo-saxon d'appel du damage
control c'est à dire qu'à la base
c'était quand même ce qu'il y avait de
moins risqué mais c'est un peu comment
dirais-je une
une minimisation des risques immédiats
c'est une préférence pour le présent si
j'ose dire c'est à dire que ils ont
minimisé les risques immédiat le
président a minimiser les risques
immédiat
mon sentiment profond en se disant qu'il
allait quand même enfin qui trouverait
bien un truc pour s'en sortir et ça
c'est la lecture du passé qui nous
apprend ça c'est à dire les gilets
jaunes il y a le grand débat national
voilà alors
ça nous amène effectivement la prise de
parole du président demain on va y venir
tout de suite avec vous email un mot
vous lui intervenir juste pour rebondir
sur l'idée que le débat a changé de
nature je voulais juste rappeler que ça
avait été aussi le cas sur des
mouvements sociaux qui ont surpris à
l'époque il y a eu une nuit debout sous
François Hollande les gilets jaunes sous
Emmanuel Macron le premier quinquennat à
chaque fois on a une mesure sociale où
fiscale comme dans le cas des gilets
jaunes et très vite les revendications
se transforment nuit debout et ses
grands assemblées en remettaient en
cause tout le régime les gilets jaunes
c'était cette fameuse revendication du
référendum d'initiative populaire et
puis et puis là en ce moment voilà le le
la remise en cause des outils
autoritaires de la 5ème qui apparaissent
de plus en plus archaïque par rapport à
ce que la société recèle comme attente
d'écoute des participations donc d'après
les dernières informations on va parler
de la prise de parole d'Emmanuel Macron
il ne souhaiterait ni dissolution ni
remaniement ni référendum on l'a vu dans
le sujet de Jérôme Rabier en revanche
bon il parle bien ça on en fissure de ma
13h au JT TF1 France 2 le président
gagne enfin s'adresser aux Français
puisque jusqu'à maintenant la
mobilisation sociale qui s'est musclé
ces derniers jours avec le 49-3 n'avait
pas eu d'écho du côté de l'Elysée qui
était plutôt
occupé à négocier avec les républicains
pour s'assurer de leur vote et
l'exercice n'a pas été très réussi
c'est pas la première fois qu'Emmanuel
Macron choisit ce rendez-vous en pleine
crise sociale il avait utilisé notamment
ce créneau en avril 2018 pendant les
grèves contre la réforme de la SNCF
juste quelques mois avant l'apparition
des gilets jaunes j'y vois pas de lien
le choix n'est pas anodin c'est un moyen
de toucher à une cible particulière
c'est la France des retraités il a
peut-être besoin de les rassurer la
France rurale aussi qui rentre déjeuner
chez elle le midi et peut-être aussi
cette population qui est moins sensible
aux mobilisations sociales actuelles on
sent aussi l'idée de toucher la France
des territoires de parler à cette France
périphérique représentée dans les rangs
des gilets jaunes qui réapparu ça et là
dans les manifestations de ces dernières
semaines je parle notamment des
manifestations qui avaient lieu dans les
petites villes et les villes moyennes
alors 15 à 20 minutes et c'est un
entretien avec les deux journalistes
vedettes de TF1 et de France 2 donc pas
de discours officiel circuler il n'y a
rien a priori à annoncer au-delà de la
forme qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre de
ça alors a priori donc pas d'annonce sur
un éventuel retrait de la réforme ni
même une suspension puisque le texte a
été adopté par le Parlement même s'il
est pas voté la motion de censure
retoquée alors s'il y a pas de
changement qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre
quel intérêt à parler alors peut-être le
Président nous offrira une énième
séquence du changement de méthode
nécessaire c'est un petit peu ce qu'on
entend une rhétorique qui l'a maintes
fois utilisé durant son précédent
quinquennat et qu'il a encore martelé
d'ailleurs lors des vœux en début 2023
mais qui n'a jamais vraiment réussi à
appliquer ou alors est-ce qu'il ira
piocher dans les réformes programmées
celles qui sont à venir histoire de se
projeter vers des jours meilleurs des
jours heureux au hasard la réforme des
institutions peut-être pour répondre à
cette demande d'une meilleure démocratie
dont on parlait Macron a d'ailleurs
commencé les concertations sur le sujet
mais c'est une porte de sortie un peu
maigre parce que l'urgence et on l'a dit
plusieurs fois elle est là avec le chaos
chaque soir dans la rue depuis jeudi
dernier jour du 49-3 et puis ça sera
peut-être difficile aussi d'entendre
parler démocratie un président qui n'a
eu de cesse de mépriser les cours de
transmission pourtant essentielle que
sont les syndicats les élus et même les
parlementaires allez on va vous entendre
les uns les autres merci Émilie d'avoir
ouvert le débat sur ce chapitre Macron
première question tiens Daniel Lévy
est-ce qu'elle est attendue c'est-à-dire
que est-ce qu'il y a une prise de parole
présidentielle attendue par les Français
est-ce que c'était exprimé dans
certaines enquêtes d'opinion depuis tout
pas du tout c'est intéressant ça a été
un vrai médiatique ça a été un vrai
message qui a été porté de la part de
responsable politique pour de bonnes ou
de mauvaises raisons mais en tout cas
pas du tout et on peut d'ailleurs se
rappeler que lors de ces deux dernières
interventions de télévisuelles il a pété
deux fois à 20h sur France 2 si je me
trompe pas il n'avait pas forcément fait
un pic d'audience c'est une forme de
féminisme de dire les choses de cette
manière-là et même dans le cadre de
cette deuxième intervention qui pour le
coup ne parlait pas de politique
internationale mais parler de politique
nationale il y avait même perdu un
million de téléspectateurs entre la
première et la deuxième intervention
nouveau format mais parfois quand même
malgré tout parce que le président
parlait parce qu'en fait il y avait des
enjeux en matière de pouvoir d'achat des
enjeux à l'égard de l'Ukraine etc que ça
soit attendu ça n'a pas vraiment été le
cas là on est quand même face à une
situation où les Français se disent
globalement le président de la réplique
ne changera pas et ne bougera pas
qu'il pouvait rien annoncer quoi
il y a une forme en fait quand vous
regardez dans les enquêtes d'opinion
qu'on a notamment nous été amené à
produire qu'on voyait bien qu'il y avait
un soutien massif de l'opinion qui n'a
quasiment pas varié depuis janvier
dernier et dans un même élan la
perception ou l'anticipation que le
gouvernement quoi qu'il en coûte entre
guillemets serait amené à faire adopter
la loi qu'elle soit avec le 49-3 ou avec
un vote au sein du au sein du Parlement
qui plus est en termes de très d'image
aujourd'hui il y a quand même des trades
du président réplique qui se sont
quelque peu abîmés et notamment en fait
cette capacité à pouvoir être en
empathie avec les Français cette
capacité à pouvoir être justement proche
des gens de comprendre les
préoccupations de la part de nos
compatriotes ce sont déjà des
qualificatifs qui n'existaient pas de
manière massif préalablement et qui se
sont dégradés au cours de l'appel
récente alors peut-être que le format
dont parlait Émilie tout à l'heure vis
justement à patiner un petit peu ceci
mais que pour autant les Français ne se
disent pas vivement l'intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron et on n'est pas du
tout du tout dans ce regard là en se
disant que comme vous l'avez indiqué
d'ailleurs c'est quasiment que des
propositions par la négative et pas
un changement de Premier ministre bof
etc et le problème pour la dissolution
mais la dissolution c'est une
politiquement c'est à dire
alors donc le problème me semble-t-il de
l'équation Macron c'est ça c'est à dire
que il faut qu'il retrouve
l'idée géniale l'idée géniale qu'on
n'attendait pas donc moi la seule chose
qui m'intéresse est-ce que demain il va
trouver quelque chose qui est capable de
nous épater or et j'en termine par là il
a déjà
usé beaucoup de cordes enfin beaucoup de
films de sa ficelle c'est-à-dire que le
grand débat national c'est une enfin je
veux dire je ne je ne parle pas dans un
enthousiasme militant mais c'était une
super trouvaille en termes politiques
ça a calmé le jeu ça lui a permis de
reprendre la main ça a donné des ordres
d'antenne faciles aux chaînes d'infos
il y avait plein de bénéficiaires
secondaires de tout cela ensuite
il nous a fait le coup du changement de
méthode ça y est c'est fait
le Conseil national de la refondation
c'est encore très aimable de dire que ça
a fait cheat et donc par conséquent sur
le plan de l'écoute du changement de
méthode et tout
il a enfin à mon avis il a grillé toutes
ces cartouches donc j'attends de voir si
sa créativité va aller se poser ailleurs
mais
Émilie et ensuite
pas deux pas de remaniement pas de
dissolution il y a quand même pas
d'issue politique de l'autre côté non
plus et c'est ce qu'ils ont beaucoup mis
en avant hier c'est-à-dire de dire
finalement il y a pas de débouché sur
votre motion de censure déjà elle est
retoquée quand même même si c'est à neuf
voix et surtout il n'y a pas d'entente
possible dans ces oppositions politiques
ou en tout cas dans ce qu'on voit
actuellement
et juste pour revenir sur en effet il
est peut-être pas attendu demain à 13h
mais il est très crit dans les
manifestations c'est à dire que c'est
pas Elisabeth band finalement elle ne
joue pas le rôle de paratonnerre c'est
lui qui est visé sur la réforme des
retraites et qui est très critiquée dans
c'est très peu Élisabeth borne c'est lui
qui revient on a vu son effigie brûlée
même très très violent des images assez
violentes donc c'est quand même lui
personnellement qui est attaqué même
s'il est pas attendu alors si on essaye
de lister des idées possibles enfin
escale on a une grande conférence
sociale sur le sens et la valeur du
travail par exemple ok sauf que les
syndicats ont ils imaginent pas venir
dans la joie et la bonne humeur
s'installer autour de la table quoi ils
en voudront pas enfin Laurent Berger l'a
dit dans une grande interview à
Libération il lui faudra pas compter sur
nous pour faire comme si de rien n'était
comme avant et bon on peut pas leur en
vouloir quand même
ils ont voilà ils ont une fin de une fin
de non-recevoir non la met la discussion
qu'on a elle-même et un peu lunaire pour
enfin pardon du coup sur investi
peut-être c'est pas une critique comme
vous mais sur investi peut-être un peu
critique ce que ce qu'on peut attendre
de la démocratie française mais on est
en train de se dire tiens qu'est-ce que
le président
sa propre majorité ils sont là ils
attendent ils savent pas à quels sont
aussi vont être mangés même beaucoup
voulaient aller au vote ils l'ont dit
dans la presse bon ils sont ils se font
claqués la porte donc tout ça donne une
image quand même assez assez terrible et
bonne solution je crois pas qui qui en
est à part un Big Bang institutionnel
mais bon qui peut pas improviser comme
ça en deux jours et juste pour terminer
là-dessus je pense que rien ne sera à la
hauteur quelque part parce que en fait
le coeur de cette réforme des retraites
et ça ça a été dit par Sophie Coignières
c'est que effectivement il en fait il en
fait un cas important parce que c'est le
cœur de sa politique dont il n'a pas
varié depuis 2017 là les réformes
structurelles l'adaptation de la France
à la mondialisation néolibéral etc c'est
le cœur qui ne bouge pas il y a des
adaptations de temps en temps voilà il y
a la pandémie on s'ajuste à la
conjoncture mais au fond c'est ce qu'il
protège et c'est bien ça qui fait réagir
très fort la société parce qu'il va
encore plus le curseur un peu plus loin
que les précédents gouvernement qui
avait déjà heurté parfois des
préférences des Français et c'est ça qui
bloque allez un tout dernier mot là
dessus parce qu'effectivement on va pas
passer tout le débat que peut nous dire
quand même la préoccupation principale
des Français c'est le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui sauf que le quoi qu'il en
coûte ça fait déjà 3 ans qu'on y est
donc est-ce qu'il peut est-ce que ça
peut être un axe par exemple ça de
communication de ça peut être un axe si
tenté qu'il considère qu'il allait marge
de manœuvre ben voilà mais c'est c'est
très fort mais elle est aussi faite pour
envoyer un message de d'orthodoxie
budgétaire et une des raisons pour
lesquelles en fait les Français
n'étaient pas persuadés qu'il était
absolument urgent de faire cette réforme
elle s'inscrit autour de deux dimensions
qui sont très claires la première
dimension c'est que c'était la question
de la dette et des déficitations
constitué la 18e motivation de vote de
nos compatriotes donc c'est à dire 9e en
fait au cours de la première élection
d'Emmanuel Macron donc on voit bien
l'écart notamment liés ou quoi qu'il en
coûte et puis le deuxième aspect une
forme de crédibilité politique initiale
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était quelque peu
abîmé et quand on regarde en fait les
motivations de vote des électeurs à
l'égard d'Emmanuel Macron
le programme politique d'Emmanuel Macron
était le parmi les différents candidats
celui qui était le moins soutenu et en
tout cas la moindre motivation de vote
le seul pour lequel il y a une petite
différence c'est genre la salle pour
montrer en fait la différence autrement
vous prenez tous les autres candidats à
l'élection présidentielle ils avaient
tous un poids plus important de leur
programme politique dans les motivations
de vote de chacun des électeurs donc on
a vraiment voté autour de la posture de
chef d'État autour la capacité à pouvoir
gérer le pays et faire en sorte que son
gouvernement globalement tourne bien si
je peux utiliser cette expression là
mais pas sur le fond politique donc
c'est deux conditions-là n'étaient pas
réunis pour lancer la réforme des
retraites l'autre grande inconnu
évidemment de ces prochains jours et on
se projette là déjà sur la journée de
jeudi c'est la mobilisation populaire
contre cette réforme vous écoutez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il a souhaite
toujours plus forte il appelle
maintenant à une censure populaire
puisque le processus de la censure
parlementaire n'a pas fonctionné
le moment est venu de passer à la
censure populaire
nous sommes appelés par les
organisations syndicales
à une mobilisation générale jeudi
prochain
entre temps il y a déjà des consignes de
grève reconductibles qui s'appliquent
je forme le vœu que cette censure
populaire s'exprime massivement
en tout lieu en toute circonstance
et qu'elle nous permette d'obtenir le
retrait du texte parce que cet objectif
reste sur la table
neuf voies de différence ne suffisent
pas à nous faire changer d'avis
neuvois de différence
dans une assemblée comme celle-ci ne
suffisent pas à donner une consigne au
pays voilà dans ces conditions c'est par
les méthodes de la démocratie sociale
qu'il va falloir imposer la décision
parce que naturellement ça nous sert
strictement à rien de gémir au pied du
prince pour lui demander de retirer la
loi il faut que le peuple s'emmêle et
c'est ce qu'il va faire alors cette
déclaration de Jean-Luc Mélenchon Sophie
Coignières alors dans les expressions
qu'on entend beaucoup depuis 24 heures
il y avait le vent du boulet et puis il
y a aussi le spectre des gilets jaunes
voilà si on essaie de comparer ce qui
est en train de se passer avec le
mouvement des gilets jaunes qu'est-ce
que vous en dites mais effectivement
enfin on peut faire
on peut se livrer à l'examen des
différences et des ressemblances une des
grandes ressemblances c'est
effectivement
l'aspect j'allais dire
décentralisée spontanée de
qui consiste à condamner les violences
sur les condamnés c'est-à-dire à dire
les violences c'est bien malheureux mais
vous rendez bien compte que c'est la
faute du gouvernement et du président de
la République que il suffit qu'il retire
leur texte et il y aura plus de violence
et que
de manière inverse aujourd'hui Elisabeth
Bordes qui a beaucoup pris la parole
lors de ces questions au Gouvernement
sur des modes assez différents
d'ailleurs
enfin évidemment accuser les oppositions
je reprends la parole parce qu'on a cet
extrait de l'une des prises de parole de
la première ministre alors elle
s'adresse à la présidente du groupe LFI
Mathilde pano écouter
madame
la presse hier soir votre violence
verbale a déborder dans la rue mais
alors là
[Applaudissements]
au contraire vous continuez sans roulage
votre attaque systématique des
institutions républicaines vous vous en
prenez aux policiers et aux gendarmes
vous remettez en cause leur travail leur
comportement doit être exemplaire et ils
le savent tous signalement et
systématiquement examiner pour
[Musique]
ma hommage il nous protège il protège
nos institutions et l'ordre républicain
allez débats dans le débat je commence
avec vous Sophie Coignières parce que je
vous ai interrompu est-ce que vous êtes
en partie tout ou partie d'accord avec
la première ministre là-dessus sur la
part de responsabilité de les filles
dans la violence dans les rues oui je
suis en partie d'accord mais pas
totalement d'accord je pense qu'il y a
quand même comment dirais je dirais
responsabilités relativement partagée
dans cette ben voilà dans ces violences
et d'ailleurs on voit bien enfin moi
j'ai été sidérée pour revenir sur ces
questions au gouvernement il y a une
question je crois de la présidente du
groupe élevé donc les Verts qui qui
s'adresse à Elizabeth borde pour dire
enfin pour faire un gros une question
sur les violences policières assez
musclées et Elisabeth borde ne répond
pas sur les violences policières nous
dit pas un mot c'est-à-dire elle dit
même pas ce qu'on peut entendre c'est à
dire voilà le dispositif est fait pour
etc etc enfin il y a mille choses à dire
Elizabeth borde répond
sûr la légitimité de la réforme des
retraites etc etc et j'ai été frappé par
cet étrange dialogue c'est juste dire
parce que effectivement on voit bien que
que ça enfin que cette que ce discours
là de la part de la première ministre ne
va pas arranger les choses alors
maintenant effectivement est-ce que les
filles et en partie responsable des
violences policières oui ça me paraît
difficile de dire le contraire des
violences policières les violences dans
la rue excusez-moi votre avis famille
Escalona
non je sais pas sur quelle base eux ils
se contentent de s'opposer à l'Assemblée
c'est pas les filles qui envoient les
gens dans les rues
des gens à théoriser la conflictualité
depuis des années et donc c'est la
confiance ce climat à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi ça sa stratégie
en démocratie c'est ça moi je trouve que
c'est ça c'est très bien et elle est
organisé et puis à l'Assemblée on a eu
beaucoup d'épisodes
pas par exemple on voit des des
permanences élus qui ont vu soit voté au
Sénat pour la réforme des tas de soi qui
n'ont pas voté qui ont rejeté la motion
de censure là il y en a eu encore à
Amiens pour un ulr à Reims pour un élu
horizon voilà leur permanent leurs
taguer attaquer bon bien sûr non mais la
nuance que j'exprime c'est qu'à mon avis
il y a beaucoup plus d'effets moi je
considère à titre personnel que cette
réforme est à la fois la méthode et le
contenu est une brutalisation du corps
social et ça va encore plus loin à cause
de ce fameux 49-3 dont on parle depuis
plusieurs jours donc à mon avis c'est
beaucoup plus ça qui crée des réactions
dans la société qu'on peut ne pas
partager plutôt que d'aller chercher les
oppositions tout à fait d'accord je
pense que la responsabilité des des
femmes et les hommes politiques c'est
quand même de maîtriser leurs paroles et
de pas appeler forcément à la violence
donc bon et j'ajoute pardon c'est très
intéressant ce qui était ici sur le fait
qu'elle répond pas sur les violences
policières elle va plus loin elle dit je
le rends hommage parce qu'on voit bien
que le dernier la dernière ligne qui
reste en fait face à ce corps social qui
réagit d'une manière qu'on peut parfois
contester à juste titre et bien la
dernière ligne c'est l'appareil
répressif et les gilets jaunes c'est ce
qui s'était passé la première ministre
alors qu'il y a 65 policiers gendarmes
qui ont été blessés c'est quand même son
rôle de rendre hommage aux forces de
l'ordre ou alors toutes les
brutalisations qui ont été documenter et
on sait on sait même les chercheurs les
plus modérés qui travaillent depuis des
années sur sur le phénomène des
violences policières sur le maintien de
l'ordre ne cesse de dire qu'il y a un
problème même les anciennes de BFM TV on
peut pas dire qu'ils sont anti-pouvoirs
qui sont comme Mediapart tout le temps à
chercher à critiquer je viens même eux
constat qu'il y a un énorme Émilie
du mot sur Instagram ou je sais plus sur
brut de violence policière mais tout à
fait mais si on prend un tout petit peu
de recul et puisqu'on parlait des gilets
jaunes il y a eu quand même se précédent
c'est à dire que les gilets jaunes est
arrivé à cette violence terrible en
décembre 2018 et qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé il y a eu une enveloppe quand même
délivrée c'est pas une petite enveloppe
qui a été délivrée ça a été plus de 17
milliards d'euros de pouvoir d'achat en
réaction et il y a eu exactement la même
chose c'est-à-dire je ne vois pas je ne
vois pas je ne vois pas le problème je
continue avec ma taxe carburant jusqu'à
ce qui est assez violent et quelque part
ce message il est passé c'est-à-dire je
deviens visible que quand je commence à
m'attaquer aux élus ce qui est terrible
ce qui est terrible mais c'est très
intéressant
en fait de dire il y a cette possibilité
là il faut pouvoir moi j'y a juste un
élément que je trouve à discuter c'est
que Emmanuel Macron cette réforme il l'a
voulait mais il la voulait pas forcément
dans cet objet là la première réforme
qu'il avait souhaité c'était une réforme
à points beaucoup plus ambitieuse de 64
ans venait beaucoup plus d'Edouard
Philippe qui l'a remis sur la table pour
séduire la droite mais c'était pas
forcément donc
il y avait moyen de rediscuter cette
ambition du projet de réforme de
retraite alors pour conclure ce chapitre
deux aspects le premier aspect c'est de
rappeler que quand même Laurent Berger
et Philippe Martinez depuis quelques
semaines disent on n'est pas en train de
souff sur les braises on est en train de
chercher à éviter il y ait un
embrasement trop important du pays donc
il y avait déjà cette interrogation qui
existait avant et je crois qu'on l'avait
déjà dit sur ce plateau en disant on ne
sait pas ce qui se passera après et il y
a une risque en fait que ça échappe
aujourd'hui au confédérations syndicales
donc on a vu ce qui se passe depuis
jeudi dernier on verra ce qui se passera
jeudi alors que c'est l'appel des
organisations des confédérations
syndicales et puis le deuxième aspect
c'est d'un point de vue d'opinion on a
fait une grande enquête il y a quelques
semaines pour challenge le rapport à la
démocratie des Français on a un tiers
des Français qui déclarent qu'ils
comprennent le fait qu'il puisse y avoir
des violences qui soient exercées et que
ça monte à un jeune sur deux âgé de
moins de 35 ans et un sympathisant la
France insoumise sur deux qui dit du
manière générale qu'ils comprennent pas
forcément dire qu'il cautionne ou qu'ils
sont favorables légitimation c'est une
compréhension c'est une forme de
compréhension mais en tout cas c'est pas
une condamnation ferme de la part de ses
franges et ça c'est nouveau à ce niveau
là c'est nouveau et il y a d'une manière
tendance
une baisse de la confiance tendance à
les garder responsables des acteurs
politiques et une interrogation sur le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie cette
capacité à pouvoir être un relais de la
colère sociale
moins d'une dizaine de minutes dans ce
débat on va parler des républicains le
parti LR avec Quentin calmé qui est
juste derrière le rideau magique de sens
public bonsoir Quentin bienvenue
nouvelle crise interne évidemment chez
LR je l'ai dit tout à l'heure à 19
députés qui ont va être voté en faveur
de de la motion de censure comment s'est
passé le jour d'après et bien la
première étape c'était un conseil
stratégique qui avait lieu au siège du
parti ce matin autour de la table de
nombreux cadres du parti et le
journaliste de Marianne Jules pecquenard
qui nous raconte un peu les échanges
comme ça on peut voir qu'est-ce qui dit
quoi autour de la table regardez
Eric Ciotti on avait l'opportunité
historique d'être la boussole du
gouvernement Michel Tabarro a une
députée qui dit il y avait une vraie
fracture au groupe au sein du groupe de
l'Assemblée on s'est ridiculisé plus
tard dans la Réunion Bruno Retailleau
qui dit on doit pas mettre la poussière
sous le tapis on est trop faible pour
diviser et qui s'adresse à Erick ce type
ou une retailleux qui dit tu n'as fait
aucune erreur depuis le début ce à quoi
eriki comment ça s'en prendre Aurélien
Pradier est-ce que tu es encore avec
nous et ça c'est toute la question qui
restait en suspente on a eu une
confirmation plus tard dans la journée
Pradier à affirmer qu'il souhaitait
rester au sein des LR malgré tout c'est
ce que nous indiquait une c'est natrice
proche direction tique on a eu au
téléphone alors justement il y a eu
ensuite plusieurs étapes notamment au
Parlement les sénateurs LR étaient
réunis ce matin et ils ont évoqué ce cas
Pradier exactement parmi ceux qui ont
bien voulu répondre à nos journalistes
qui lui ont entendu des micros on
entendait la volonté de tourner la page
Pradier écouter par exemple Marc
Philippe de presse certains membres de
nos collègues députés on fait passer des
considérations personnelles voire de
buzz personnel par rapport à un intérêt
général à des positions que nous
défendons depuis des années est-ce qu'il
faut pour autant les exclure je pense
que il faut commencer par clarifier une
ligne des républicains clarifier des
règles du jeu
et ensuite on pourra appliquer des
règlements quand quelqu'un fera attaque
on pourra siffler un penalty il faut le
dire aussi il y a un autre argument
massue les frondeurs chez les LR1 autour
de Aurélien Pradier il représente pas
moins d'un tiers de l'effectif total du
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale difficile
de se couper d'un tel nombre de députés
mais on l'entend certains LR appellent à
éclaircir leur ligne politique Éric
Ciotti les a entendus il va lancer un
grand débat de refondation des
républicains a-t-il dit ce matin après
le conseil stratégique et il y a
d'autres LR qui s'imaginent d'aller plus
loin dans le rapprochement avec la
macronie oui peut y avoir une
recomposition avec les LR et si c'était
la solution pour elle à faire de revenir
en quelque sorte au pouvoir d'une
certaine façon c'est effectivement ce
que nous a dit ce que nous en dit
certains sénateurs mais il faudrait un
cadre très précis écoutez le sénateur
François Noël buffet si la situation ça
dépend beaucoup de la situation
un jour devait amener cette idée là sur
le tétée en toute trans et sur la base
des idées qui sont les nôtres et des ça
peut être qu'un contrat c'est une forme
contractuelle un peu à la demande mais
ça peut pas être autrement sommes-nous
dans ce moment-là je ne suis pas je ne
sais pas mais en tous les cas si par
hypothèse il fallait imaginer une
situation de nature ça peut être qu'un
contrat sur l'Allemand un contrat de
gouvernement qui soit large voilà Thomas
on le voit après chez les républicains
c'est la carte de l'apaisement pour ne
pas aller vers une scission et des
réflexions sur l'avenir de la famille
politique merci beaucoup Quentin calmé
Sophie Cognard je viens vers vous sur ce
ce contrat de gouvernement à l'allemande
je reprends les termes de du sénateur
buffet bon on l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est pas exactement dans notre culture
politique mais surtout est-ce que on
peut imaginer ça au sortir d'une telle
séquence avec un parti LR aussi divisé
et affaibli mais d'ailleurs enfin le
fond le fond de la question c'est aussi
quand même que il y a 19 députés LR
voter contre un texte stellaire enfin
j'exagère un tout petit peu mais à peine
donc enfin c'est quand même une
situation un peu improbable certes ils
ont fait ils ont voté au-delà du texte
pour enfin pour exprimer une certaine
défiance vis-à-vis de l'exécutif mais
tout de même c'est quand même assez
étonnant de voir puisqu'on parle
beaucoup de bras d'honneur en ce moment
on est encore dans une sorte de bras
d'honneur fait par 19 députés à l'air au
sénateur LR qui avait réécrit le projet
donc ça c'est le ça c'est le premier
problème deuxième problème
le pacte républicain ou le compromis à
l'Allemand doit faire un peu il y a
mille façons de l'exprimer moi
j'aimerais voir sur quelle base encore
une fois revenons à l'Assemblée
nationale car c'est là où est le
problème ou sinon on peut on voit bien
que des majorités textes par textes sont
trouvables avec les sénateurs c'est la
démonstration on a été faite avec avec
la réforme des retraites mais à
l'Assemblée nationale on parlait de la
validation menée par signifie le groupe
LR et aujourd'hui totalement zadisée
aussi donc avec qui vous faites un
contrat de gouvernement du côté de la
majorité et de l'exécutif c'est un peu
compliqué de se de signer avec des
partenaires que pas montrer leur
fiabilité et du côté de LR et bien ça
veut dire effectivement ce couper le
bras en se disant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ben on fait ça avec notre majorité mais
la majorité de quoi c'est à dire
aujourd'hui les deux tiers d'un groupe
avec d'un autre côté les les frondeurs
entre guillemets il faut bien les
appeler comme ça qui qui moi ça m'amuse
beaucoup quand j'entends dire oui non
mais il faudrait déjà poser des règles
donc ensuite quand il est franchiront
bien on pourra les sanctionner mais le
problème n'est pas là les lignes rouges
elles étaient posées signées la motion
de censure du groupe liote c'était une
ligne rouge votez celle du Rassemblement
National 3 députés quand même c'était
inimaginable il y a encore quelques
temps donc le franchissement de ligne
rouge c'est fait et puis sans sanction
derrière parce que le parti ça
faiblirait trop
il y a un moment où c'est pas juste se
couper un bras mais c'est se couper plus
que ça Fabien votre votre analyse de la
fragilité à l'air parce que c'est quand
même aussi l'un des constats qu'on doit
faire ce qui se passe quand on
aujourd'hui on dit souvent la vie
politique elle est un peu structurée en
trois pôles on a beaucoup dit ça entre
la gauche rouge verte la macronie la
droite radicale LR c'est un parti déchu
qui qui est tiraillé entre entre ces
pôles qui a du mal à trouver sa place et
on en a là l'illustration moi bon dans
le bouquin je défends je défends la
proportionnelle je dis au moins avec ça
chacun se base sur ses couleurs au
premier tour et puis ensuite justement
on a la recherche d'un contrat de
gouvernement alors peut-être pas dans
notre culture en tout cas sous la 5e ce
qu'on a connu d'autres d'autres régimes
avec parfois quand même des résultats
pas que de l'instabilité donc il y
aurait moyen de faire autrement et à mon
avis ce serait ce serait souhaitable
pour justement la stabilité
du pays et pour des vrais compromis
parce qu'on voit bien là que c'est
soi-disant institution stable qu'on nous
vante là elle produisent pas des
résultats très probants quoi allez on
est quasiment à la fin du débat mais il
y a un nom qu'on a pas prononcé c'est
celui de Laurent Wauquiez parce que il
avait une stratégie alors là quasiment
pas entendu depuis des mois il y a une
stratégie d'attente mais là la situation
est-ce que est-ce qu'elle peut l'obliger
à accélérer dans sa dans sa stratégie il
est et puis d'attente et puis surtout
pour récupérer quelle partie il faut un
parti dans quel état quoi et d'autant
plus que quand on analyse les résultats
parmi les 19 députés qui ont voté la
motion de censure il y a un certain
nombre qui sont considérés comme étant
proches de Laurent Wauquiez alors après
est-ce que c'est un jeu de billard à
plusieurs bandes en se disant il faut
faire tomber le gouvernement et dans ce
contexte là apparaître comme étant le
Sauveur personne peut savoir tant que le
robot qui ne s'est pas clairement
exprimé
d'une manière ou d'autre oui il va être
amené forcément à prendre la parole et à
donner à sa position on sait qu'il était
FA à la réforme on sait que globalement
les messages qu'il faisait passer
étaient plutôt un vote en faveur
également de la réforme après chaque
député regardez également ce qui se
passe dans sa circonscription écoute ces
électeurs regardent dans le rétroviseur
le vote au cours de la dernière élection
législative dans leur circonscriptions
ils peuvent se dire que leur propre
intérêt en dehors de l'intérêt du parti
c'est peut-être soit de voter contre le
gouvernement soit éventuellement on les
appelle il faut les auto-entrepreneurs
c'est députés soit les fondateurs mais
je pensais à l'appellation fradeur qui
quand même le la droite c'est beaucoup
moqué de François Hollande à l'époque il
avait les frondeurs donc entendre ça
pour eux ça doit ça doit faire mal à
leurs oreilles quand même la situation
aujourd'hui malgré tout intéressante
parce qu'on se rappelle que la stratégie
d'Édouard Philippe c'était d'affaiblir
durablement la droite et il disait je
sens que la poutre travaille encore
alors là peut-être qu'elle a travaillé
un peu trop fort
quand c'est les circonscriptions qui
comptent le plus et qui a pas moyen de
mettre tout le monde d'accord c'est bien
la preuve que bon il manque de ce parti
à changé de statut on peut dire salut
Parti socialiste aussi d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à de ce débat je vais rappeler le titre
de vos livres évidemment la tyrannie de
la médiocrité Sophie Coignières livre
qui est publié aux éditions de
l'Observatoire et puis Fabien Escalona
une république à bout de souffle qui
vient de paraître aux éditions du Seuil
merci encore